[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est melissa maulin depuis cette
semaine je suis de retour pour ma
première chronique de 2021 et j'aimerais
apporter la tension sur le sujet du
projet de loi c-15 kita projet de loi
qui veut apporter de l'avant la
déclaration des droits des peuples
autochtones comment elle implantée au
canada
gvt est critique il ya des espoirs aussi
qu'ils sont fondés sur ce projet de loi
le certains me critique vu comme la
déclaration des droits des peuples
autochtones a été fait au niveau
international et bien le subjugue et ou
droit canadien serait justement puis un
droit international et du droit national
ce qui enlèverait du pouvoir justement à
ce projet de loi là il faut pas oublier
que dans le projet de loi
on reconnaît quand même que la
déclaration des droits des peuples
autochtones on veut connaître certains
aspects comme le droit à
l'autodétermination alors si on met le
droit à l'autodétermination des
communautés comme sous justement la
constitution canadienne comme l'article
est ce qu'on enlève aux communautés
autochtones du pouvoir de droit à
l'autodétermination et qu'est ce que ça
veut dire qu'est ce que ça ait pris pour
oublier que présentement en 2000 on a
découvert justement que les systèmes de
leadership sont multi avait comme une
autochtone on a souvent eu l'impression
qu'il n'y avait que les chefs ou l'apn
alors qu'il existe aussi donc forme de
leadership très légitime la même manière
que les chefs dans les communautés leçon
eh bien on va parler d'échec ancestraux
et ces groupes le n'ont pas pu avoir
accès à ces projets de loi lors n'ont
pas été consultés justement par rapport
au projet de loi c 15 et donc ça devient
problématique parce qu'on va tous se
servir d'un organisme tel que l'apn pour
passer un cheval de troie légal alors
que l'on parle de consultation vous
parle de droit à l'autodétermination
dont le droit de choisir pour soi même
et en faisant ce genre de le parcours le
et bien on diminue justement ce droit à
l'autodétermination donc c'est un des
aspects qui boucle est un autre aspect
qui peut être vraiment mis de l'avant
c'est que c'est encore et des lois qui
sont écrits par des allochtone pour les
autochtones donc il ya une problématique
encore au coeur de ça alors qu'on
reconnaît juste
le droit à l'autodétermination je vous
rappellerai que les oueds souhaitait
justement une forme que le public à
raser ou eu de voir comment le droit à
l'autodétermination en tant que peuple
autochtone peut-être compliqué pour le
canada donc sérieusement je vous invite
à vous intéresser au projet de loi c-15
en espérant qu'ils ne disparaissent pas
puisqu'on voit rentrant d'élections mais
c'est surtout que c'est extrêmement
intéressant de voir comment on va aller
de l'avant comment ça aussi mais du feu
donc dos d'une voix dans le feu
justement de mouvance comme le pensent
les bacs retourner nous les roms alors
énormément de choses qui va tourner
autour de céder cet aspect là et on va
voir si ça va être peuvent eux pu ou
vraiment une loi qui va avoir des dents
qui va permettre justement aux
communautés autochtones de prendre
justement les rênes de leur commune ou
alors je rate une belle semaine je vous
invite à vous y intéresser je vous
invite à nous envoyer des questions et
je vous souhaite une belle semaine